(marching music)
♪ Brickleberry ♪
- Will you say that
again, so I can record it?
Then I'll have
something to play back
when I forget why I hate you.
Oh, yeah yeah, no
I read about that
in Highly Unlikely
Bullshit Magazine.
- I'm bringing a friend to be
my date, so fingers crossed.
- By friend he means hooker,
and by date he means shallow
grave by the railroad.
- Dude, a hairy little
woodland creature
can't direct a movie.
- Uh, what about Peter Jackson?
- I hate animals.
- To be fair, most
animals hate black people.
And Mexicans.
I bet you'd like to see
my tight ass in that,
you creepy pervert.
What the (bleep) is that?
I asked for a motorcycle.
- Malloy, we both know
you're not big enough.
Besides this is just as cool.
- [Bike] I'm a big
boy, I'm a big boy.
- I am not getting
on that thing.
Winnie the Pooh never had
to deal with this bullshit.
Luckily I found
this pontoon boat.
Anybody hungry?
I'm kidding, she
probably has AIDS.
♪ Brickleberry ♪